[Music]
you know we haven't checked in on in a
while dude
and I wanted to see if he was doing well
I wanted to see if he was doing good
doing home
um obster the obster
that that's Hopey yes I swear to God
that's Opie
that's Opie this is the most recent
video this is Opie
let's talk Kathy Bates okay this is uh
Opie talks about are we sure this is not
Greg The Hammer Valentine
no this is Greg the Opie Hughes
um hold on this might be first let me
see this one's first okay let me make
sure I get these in order
uh July 2022 and this is June 16th 2022
so Junior wins first okay so this one's
first here you go
I survived the 90s I think you had the
right idea back then splitting the show
Once you felt it was not going in the
direction you felt to be honest I don't
like you but I do wish you well man
why are you laughing first off why would
you split the show is doing great and
he's in that was one of the dumbest
things ever you guys did split the show
Once you got fired and it didn't do good
so yeah that's okay
that's all right
oh my God when he does his hair like
that he really does look like one of
those ladies that would ask for a
manager
yes I don't like you
um yeah I mean
the Ona brand was so strong that it
should continued in some way
I thought I thought the uh the open
Anthony show at the end was much
different than uh the show I enjoyed
doing it was still funny to me to be
honest with you is he still doing these
these yeah he's still he's still
thinking about this and talking about
this Opie you've said this a hundred
times already uh but yeah you know what
we probably should have tried to like uh
keep the brand strong but then Anthony
made some dumb and I'll say this another
hundred times he does he did a really
dumb business move which uh which is the
theme tonight because like I said my dad
didn't think he should be a 50 50
partner back in the day and I decided
that was the right thing to do
um and and uh he he did not prove good
business sense because after after he
got fired from SiriusXM yeah he did
something so crazy and Despicable like
filming one of those co-workers [ __ ]
in the bathroom right oh no no no that
was Opie wait what yeah oh look I'm not
saying Anthony was smart for what he did
that they're not people thinking oh that
was dumb especially working for SiriusXM
you look whether you what do you think
it was funny I don't care about that but
I'm just being honest like it's serious
like Sam right they're gonna fire you do
that [ __ ] right
um because they suck
but then him acting like what he did was
good for business what he did was great
for business it was so smart for
business
um yeah things were okay for a while
there and then one day decided to
completely trash me on his uh his new
network that was about uh seven years
ago
damn that was that long ago huh yeah a
long time ago [ __ ] and uh and then at
that point it was it was never the same
he turned this whole thing into me
against him which is the dumbest [ __ ]
business move there's there was so there
was and is more was there was so much
more money to be made from the Opie and
Anthony uh brand well how come when he
when he this is a matter of record how
come when
um
when he offered you to come back and do
the Ona show remember that when Anthony
offered him after all the drama and
everything you'll come back and we do
the Illinois show on Anthony's Network
you said no if there was so much like
money in it right if it was so great how
come you kept saying that you and Jim
show was amazing and it was so good and
it was killer or you and this D Stefano
who was the other guy he had in there
that that was there for a while Christy
Stefano yeah and there was there's a
couple more odds small yeah so Kenley
yeah come on
and he decided to pull that [ __ ]
[ __ ] business power move and trash me
and I'll say it again tonight what the
[ __ ] in the end did I do to that guy
that I deserved his trashing and then I
don't know what you did to Anthony
specifically and I'm not here to defend
Anthony because he's got his own [ __ ]
problems but I got my own [ __ ]
problem but what I am saying here I can
tell you what you did to deserve the
entire staff hating you I know what you
did there for a fact I know you were
behind their backs I know for a
first-hand knowledge that you went
behind their backs I know that you filed
a bunch of AR HR reports of people that
were even after all the Anthony stuff
still had your back because they thought
you were their friends but you were
behind their back and you complained
that all of them because your show was
failing and you knew it was [ __ ]
failing because you and Jim couldn't
[ __ ] stand each other either and then
Sherrod [ __ ] was even had your [ __ ]
done with you too and killed Steve C and
yeah you know made Steve kill himself
um allegedly so besides that though you
were a [ __ ] angel here look man I
ain't [ __ ] sitting here saying
Anthony got [ __ ] problems obviously
he does however you are a big reason
this should fail dude sorry
seven plus years of it as he continues
to do it and he kind of he kind of
ruined the Opie and Anthony brand and I
guess his ego is such that he assumed if
he trashed me and destroyed me that the
entire audience would just follow him
and then I guess he would reap the
rewards and make millions and millions
of dollars but the fact is that he
doesn't make any money I don't make any
money and I will hold to the fact that I
think it was a really really dumb stupid
business move to try that uh me versus
him [ __ ] Brian Bernard 25 for the
beer fund thank you that's so
embarrassing Brian Bernard I appreciate
it Anthony offered you a job on compound
there it is so someone did ask him he's
really wanted to sign you I don't know
what that means
I'll explain it to you I'll I'll help
him out what it means is that Anthony
offered you a job at the compound Keith
really wanted to sign you
I don't know what any of that means I
don't know those people oh I'm sorry
there must be a connection thing what it
means is Anthony offered you a job on
compound Keith really wanted to sign you
he's so bad I know
I have no idea what that means like I
what is that yeah it's offered I was
offered half the business to go over
there and every time I bring it up it
infuriates Anthony because I guess he
didn't want people to know that they
reached out to me uh um okay but fine
but you so he admitted
he's stinky is his thingy
Cuban actor by the way
at least twice
I'm better at this than you but why so
you just said
that Anthony
burned it all to the ground right but
now you're also saying you offered you
half again
correct
and you said no
and offer me two giant [ __ ] deals but
that goes against all the the [ __ ]
that he was spewing that I suck and I'm
worthless and blah blah blah blah blah
yeah but I thought you said it was about
business sense why don't you [ __ ]
swallow your pride you both have a job
right now you just
completely revered into a different
opinion about the same thing yeah like
seamlessly well the problem is Opie's
turning into his mom and he knows it
was like mentally ill yeah and crazy
yeah he knows it isolated isolated doing
streams in his car like a crazy cat lady
so when I uh made that public it drove
him nuts because the two things didn't
match up I can't be worthless and and
and I can't sock and all this other
horse [ __ ] and and then on the other
side you're offering me half your
[ __ ] company yeah you can Nickelback
yeah I mean there's a lot of people that
suck that make a lot of money by the way
there's a lot of people that are falling
out and you know they don't talk for a
few years and maybe they talk some [ __ ]
back and forth and then you know yeah
you you could you could work [ __ ] out
you could work [ __ ] out [ __ ] Axl Rose
and slash say they would never tour
again now they're touring again like
yeah eventually somebody offers enough
money and you're like I do have a
mortgage yeah exactly I Opie I lives in
[ __ ] Trump Tower and he's wondering
you know
it doesn't it doesn't work
it doesn't work that way so when I
announce to the world that I absolutely
had a uh you know an offer to go over
there that drove them nuts that it made
it public but why not
no no no but why didn't you take the job
that forget that
why don't you take the job officer
yeah get the plane in my favor because
I'm like oh all this [ __ ] he said
yeah I played in your favor you're both
doing so well right now
saying about me uh how much I suck and
I'm worthless well he streams to 40
people how about this everybody enjoy
this and I put it up hey Frozen you know
you could talk down to Opie right Sunday
night should show gets better numbers
than him you're allowed to if you want
to
you could dunk on him yeah no it's true
you could dunk on him if you want
honestly I've said this before too
Opie would have more viewers if he just
streamed his View
yeah yeah you're right one of those like
24-hour Manhattan cams yeah you're right
oh my God more numbers and play some
like royalty-free chill pop music Lo-Fi
hip-hop Lo-Fi exactly yeah
of view of Manhattan with chilled music
to study to would do better than [ __ ]
Opie